now the United States has conducted a
military operation to evacuate its
Embassy staff from Sudan the Army had
agreed to help evacuate foreign
Nationals as gunfire Street battles and
airstrikes continue in the capital
Khartoum earlier two ships carrying
staff from Saudi Arabia's Embassy
arrived back home in Jeddah through Port
Sudan also on board where diplomatic
officials from other countries in the
Gulf cooperation Council the UK France
and China meanwhile are also arranging
for their Embassy staff and citizens to
be evacuated as are Iraq and Jordan Shia
britanzi has more now from Washington
D.C
for several days now we've been told
that contingency planning for an
evacuation of U.S government Personnel
from Sudan was underway they were
high-level calls between Mark milley The
Joint Chiefs and Sudanese officials
Anthony blinken and Sudanese officials
about an evacuation of some sort more
troops were being put into neighboring
countries and we were told on Friday
that a decision would be made by
President Biden very soon what we were
also constantly told there was it would
only be U.S government officials who
would be evacuated not these some 16 000
Americans thought to be in Sudan there
were several relatively testy defensive
exchanges both at the White House and at
the state department over the last few
days and by demonstration officials kept
saying look we've told American citizens
since the summer of 2021 that Sudan was
getting even more dangerous and that
they would be on their on their own
actually that message came just a few
just a week ago or so nonetheless I
think what what we'll see in the coming
days is that shadow of the Kabul
evacuation which still hangs over the
Biden Administration even when it came
to the Diplomatic Personnel we're
already seeing questions asked as to why
it took so long specifically because one
of the lessons the Biden Administration
said that they had learned from Kabul
was that an early evacuation was key
we're going to see more questions about
that in the coming days I would imagine
or fighting between Sudan's Army and the
rapid support forces is now into its
second week several ceasefires have
failed including one during Eid our
correspondent hibber Morgan reports from
the Sudanese capital
the area around the presidential Palace
and the Army headquarters in Khartoum is
the focus of intense fighting as the
Army and paramilitary group the rapid
support forces battle for control of
Sudan
many of the city's 6 million residents
are trapped in their homes with power
outages a lack of running water and
dwindling Food Supplies
they're angry that a 72-hour ceasefire
for the Muslim holiday of adulthood
hasn't held I want to say to the bow
side we are the civilians we are the
pain the price we're not supposed to
live in
in this situation we are panicking we
are panicking this we are struggling
this is too much for us both sides say
they're aware of the impact on the
Sudanese people the commander of the
rapid support forces says he's asked the
U.N for help and has spoken to Secretary
General Antonio guterres about the
humanitarian truths safe passage of
residents who want to leave and the
protection of Aid workers
even though both sides agreed to a
72-hour ceasefire people in parts of
heartum say the fighting on Saturday was
the worst they've seen and some say
they've given up on stocking up on basic
goods and are waiting for a chance to
leave
it's not easy to get a clear picture of
the situation
both sides accuse each other of bombing
residential areas
more explosions were heard on Saturday
night both sides seemed determined to
fight on leaving millions of Sudanese
fearing for their lives Heber Morgan Al
Jazeera Khartoum
Ali Ibrahim is a Nigerian medical
student studying in Sudan and he says
he's been unable to leave the country
since the fighting broke out and our
food is running short
we are stranded in Sudan because we are
trapped in this I can describe it as a
war zone
especially because we don't have food to
eat to be honest there is no water to
drink and we don't the electricity is
cut up like for almost three days right
now the students who are living outside
the university they have to migrate from
their private apartment
in to the student campus where they can
be they can have access to self-drinking
water and food to eat because outside
the shops are all closed even if you
have money you cannot get access to food
because there is no way there is no
security I was just coming out of our
house where we stayed just coming
looking searching for water to drink all
the clothes the shops were closed and
then as I was trying to still look for
water then some people like two guys
they stopped me and they took my phone
with my money even as I was coming from
the school campus tour to the mosque of
the university around 5 30 there was a
very very gunfire like a vegan firelight
very loud
to the extent like some of the students
started to have to run haphazardly
without knowing where the direction
which direction are they heading to so
it's like that's why it's very scary you
can't even sleep because it's it's like
it's unexpected at night in the morning
in the evening in the afternoon anytime
you can hear this kind of gunshot
well as we've been saying foreign
evacuations from Sudan are currently
underway let's speak to Susan page she's
a professor at Michigan law school and
also a former U.S ambassador to South
Sudan she joins us now from Anna Arbor
in Michigan Susan we've obviously had
confirmation from President Biden just
in the last half hour of the U.S
evacuation I want to start with what we
know this was obviously a complicated
Mission and I know the embassy earlier
in the day said it was too dangerous to
evacuate its civilians but they have
managed to get their diplomats out as a
former Ambassador yourself just how
risky was this
well from what I understand uh it was
probably quite dangerous given that we
were unsure from what I understand again
we were unsure who controlled the
airport in Khartoum and the airport had
been actually at the center of a lot of
the fighting uh along with nearby areas
so people were Sheltering in their homes
because it was actually just too
dangerous to get out so yeah I I think
that um no matter how many times uh
evacuations occur they're always
situation by situation and this was
difficult with fighting so near the
airport of course I believe during the
pandemic this the embassy they estimated
there was something like 19 000
Americans in the country that's a huge
number in terms of the scale of a
potential ongoing evacuation of citizens
so what does this mean for them
especially now that they don't even have
any diplomatic support there
right well generally speaking
um all embassies I mean all countries
first and foremost want to protect their
citizens their Nationals
um and their Embassy property uh Etc
um but the citizens who live in a
country when things go bad they are
advised to do the same things that
official Americans are advised to do
which is in this case was take shelter
um stay as safe as possible Etc but uh
it's difficult to try to evacuate people
and you also don't know how many people
there are where they are located even
though we do keep records
um but it's only those who decide to
register with the embassy and that's not
everyone who's in country and a lot of
people of course are dual Nationals they
may be uh partnered with a Sudanese
married to a Sudanese uh have family
friends and may not actually want to
leave despite the risk to their safety
sure Susan you just said something there
about priorities that the priority for
many embassies and foreign powers is to
make sure that they're citizens and
their diplomatic Staff first and
foremost are safe which I completely
understand I wonder though does the
evacuation now that we're seeing a
foreign Nationals potentially change the
level of perceived urgency of resolving
this conflict now for foreign powers
even if it's potentially a little
unacknowledged
um so it's always difficult if you
actually evacuate everyone from a
diplomatic Mission because that means
you don't have official eyes on the
ground and know what's happening so uh
that makes it difficult
um I can only hope that given the
complexity given how large Sudan is and
the foreign powers that have interests
not all of which are the same uh I don't
think that people will lose interest or
stop trying to help the parties and
especially the Sudanese civilians to
resolve the conflict and get some peace
back in the country Susan let me then
ask you about the mediation effort does
this change anything presumably if some
people are getting out some can get in
um it's not clear that that is actually
the case
um I I don't know I obviously I don't
work for the US government anymore
um as it's only been confirmed by uh uh
secretary blinken in the last 30 minutes
one hour
um it's unclear exactly how the
evacuation took place did
um was the airport completely secured
but it's also the airspace and where
planes are allowed to fly over and fly
into and fly out of and oftentimes it's
a special mission in which case it is a
very limited time frame that's what I'm
expecting is the case in right now
Susan page there a former U.S ambassador
to South Sudan thank you so much for
joining us here on Al Jazeera Susan
really great to get your thoughts thank
you very much for having me
well meanwhile doctors in Sudan say that
the fighting is created what they call a
catastrophic situation and forced many
hospitals to close across the Nile River
from the Capital One hospital in
onderman is doing what it can frodia car
reports
Yusuf was brought to andermann hospital
last week he wasn't involved in the
fighting between the Army and
paramilitary Rapid support forces but
he's one of its many casualties
I arrived here during the month of
Ramadan I can no longer work or move
easily I was hit by a stray bullet I
don't know from which direction it came
across the room Solomon described the
severe wounds he suffered from bullets
and shrapnel
I was hit twice and fell to the ground I
was hit in my hand and in my left side I
was brought to the hospital thank God
Almighty because now I'm okay
dozens of sick and wounded people have
come here to the undermann teaching
hospital but it's struggling to cope
fighting has prevented staff from
reaching the facility it's now operating
at just 20 percent capacity
there is a huge shortage of medical
personnel those who are now treating the
sick and the wounded are the medical
staff who arrived at the hospital last
Saturday there is no longer any way to
bring other medical staff from their
homes or areas to the hospital here of
course the doctors and nurses who have
been here since last Saturday are
completely exhausted
Sudanese doctor Syndicate says about 70
percent of hospitals close to the
fighting have had to shut and that
ambulances have come under attack
Sudan's health system was already in
crisis before the fighting Medics are
warning it now risks collapse just as
people need it the most
Freddie a car Al Jazeera